you have the ring and I see your
Schwartz is as big as mine that must be
lord farquaad's castle that's the place
do you think maybe he's compensating for
something
oh god I just
I remembered there's just this um teeny
tiny thing baby
oh no no sexual comedy is one of the
most universal and popular genres of
comedy in cinema penis sorry
Tourette's notice penis she has it too
penis it's something pretty much every
adult can relate to and has the
potential for big laughs while often
used for comedic effect I want to look
at how sexual imagery specifically
phallic symbols can be used to achieve
dramatic effects filmmakers can use
phallic symbols to tremendously
contribute to the visual storytelling of
a film penis shapes are everywhere and
while not always acknowledged there's no
doubt that skyscrapers hey what's your
funny
oh my go up guns
or even a pipe so at a certain point he
brings out this pipe and what pipe does
he bring out he brings out the Sherlock
Holmes pipe one you can say it's a
sexual thing because my bigger than
yours alright and can be treated as
phallic symbols psychologist Sigmund
Freud is famous for theorizing that we
notice these objects are phallic on a
subconscious level in a similar way of
thinking filmmakers use phallic symbols
in place of actual sex to get a
subconscious emotional reaction from the
viewer the simplest and most noticeable
use of a phallic symbol is to imply sex
in film sex is more often implied than
actually shown especially with strict
censorship during the Golden Age of
cinema that bans showing sex on screen
so instead of actual sex we see sex
represented in a phallic object take me
the pleasure town Oh what's going
Nova's lack can the object can be
anything from a bedpost in the birth of
a nation a train entering a tunnel in
North by Northwest
a man pumping gas into a woman's car and
written on the wind or a gun and
bonnie-and-clyde
through a phallic symbol we see there's
some kind of sexual relationship or
desired sexual relationship between the
two characters another common form of
phallic symbol is to show masculinity a
gun is a powerful phallic symbol that
indicates the masculinity of a character
a big gun means you're manly and the
heroes in classic action movies seem to
always have ridiculously sized weapons
and if a girl has a big gun we know
she's reversing gender roles and taking
on masculine qualities small guns on the
other hand are a sign of weakness or
vulnerability that's what I'm talking
about
noisy cricket Hey okay no no come on man
did you get a silly score at the
atomiser I get a little midget cricket
oh the gun size issue even gets
addressed in the James Bond film dr. no
as a spy bond has to conceal a small gun
but the film makes it clear that it's
still manly I've mailed with a delivery
like a brick through a plate-glass
window another example is written on the
wind
when Kyle threatens Mitch with a pistol
the small size of the gun further
reinforces the idea that Kyle is
cowardly weak and feminine he doesn't
appear threatening with such a small
weapon this parallels nicely with the
fact that Kyle is impotent and so he's
missing a major aspect of being a man
phallic symbols can also be used to
convey domination and control we see the
symbolism hyperbolically in a Clockwork
Orange a Clockwork Orange conveys the
idea that if you can expose someone
sexually you have complete and utter
domination over them so when Alex wears
a phallic mask and beats the couple with
a phallic stick or uses a phallic statue
to toy with an old lady he's asserting
his complete control over them it shows
that to physically dominate someone is
to also sexually dominate someone sex
and violence go hand in hand phallic
symbols aid the visual storytelling of
the film because they help show Alex go
from dominating to being dominated he
goes from overpowering everyone to
literally being squished by Authority
alien uses phallic symbols to convey
fear the writer of the film
intentionally made alien contain rape
imagery to make the film more terrifying
one thing that people are all disturbed
about it's sex everybody is always all
in a knot about sex I said that's how
I'm going to attack the audience I'm
going to attack them sexually and I'm
not going to go after the women in the
audience I'm gonna attack the men and
I'm gonna put in every image I can think
of that I know will make the men in the
audience cross their legs homosexual
oral rape birth the thing lays its eggs
down your throat the whole number the
parallels between the alien attacks and
real-life rape make the alien attacks
more horrific getting raped is a scary
thing and the writers use the horrors of
rape to make the alien a scarier villain
the design of the alien is very phallic
and the set pieces look equally as
phallic and vaginal this design was done
very intentionally by set designer HR
Giger key gears work was sexual and
that's the most mild thing you can say
about it if the opening of the alien
ship looks like 2d giant vaginas and a
60-foot inset we built that set it
wasn't a miniature Darren was oh my god
from the erect mouth inside alien to the
face hugger laying eggs orally to the
phallic chest Buster the whole alien is
phallic you're looking at this sort of
grey penis can I say that but instead of
using phallic symbols to show manliness
or domination alien uses phallic symbols
to show us being sexually dominated by
the alien the phallic symbols evoke
terror by making the human sexual
victims to the alien the phallic symbols
add to visual storytelling in the film
by making the alien attacks visually and
emotionally similar to sexual assault
phallic symbols work even when they're
subtle a film like the social network is
a perfect opportunity to use phallic
symbols because the whole film revolves
around the fight for power sex and high
social status the Winklevoss twins take
Mark Zuckerberg to their final Clubhouse
as a way to show off their high status
and power in order to help convince mark
to work for them they offer him a
sandwich to further show off their
luxuries and the way it's presented to
him is just so oddly phallic
and then he holds it like this and then
after mark questions their idea and
internally thinks of a better one
he holds the sandwich like this request
yeah how is that different from MySpace
or Friendster is it just a coincidence
maybe but maybe not
there's definitely a point where the
analysis of phallic symbols becomes
overkill Sigmund Freud once said
sometimes a cigar is just a cigar not
everything that looks phallic has some
sexual meaning but when used
intentionally a phallic symbol can be a
powerful visual that adds meaning to
what's happening on screen so the next
time you watch a film with your friends
and notice a phallic symbol
feel free to point it out just don't be
a huge dick about it you don't have to
be a history major or a political
scientist to see the bigger dick foreign
policy theory it sounds like this what
they have bigger dicks bomb now and of
course the bombs and the Rockets and the
bullets are all shaped like dicks it's a
subconscious need to project the penis
into other people's affairs it's called
fucking with paper thanks for watching